We want to expand the conversation now
with someone who is there on January six.
CNN law enforcement
analyst Michael Fanone is a former D.C.
Metro police officer
who was attacked by that mob
and was injured responding to the attack.
Michael, thank you so much for sharing
part of your afternoon with us.
Your response
initially to the sentencing of Stuart
Rhodes, the head of the Oath Keepers,
I certainly think that the guilty verdict
and a significant sentence
like 18 years is appropriate
although I would have agreed more with the
the government's recommendation
of 25 years.
And Michael, I'm curious.
We heard from his attorneys
they repeatedly kept saying that
the Oath Keepers meant to deter violence
that day.
Obviously we're watching video of the mob
targeting
law enforcement officers just like you.
I'm wondering
how you respond to his attorneys saying
that he's being convicted for his words.
He's being sentenced for his
words and not his actions.
Yeah.
I mean, that's something that I would
expect the defense attorney to say.
But the facts
spell out a very different story
as to Stewart Rhodes and the organization,
which he led,
participation in the violence
that was January 6th.
This is a group that came to the capital
prepared, that made preparation
in advance of January 6th.
They trained they stockpiled weapons
and ammunition
in preparation for that day.
There was a great deal of organization
and effort
facilitated by Stewart Rhodes
as the leader of the The Oath Keepers.
And obviously, we saw the violence
that played out that day.
And all of this was in an effort
to overturn the results of a free and fair
election.
And election that had its challenges
brought through the court system
60 plus times and each time found to be
upheld and legitimate.
And yet, which is why we see
the campaign for seditious conspiracy.
Right. Absolutely.
And yet we see so many of the former
president's cronies
and the former president himself
repeat the lie that there was widespread
fraud in the last election.
And on that note.
We spoke to an attorney, legal expert
in the previous hour
who said that part of the reason
for Stewart's road strategy of remaining
unrepentant through all of this
legal proceeding is because he believes
he may receive a pardon
if the former president is reelected.
I'm wondering what you make of Stewart
Rhodes potentially
being pardoned down the road
before serving a full sentence,
despite the obvious harm that the court
that the court ruled that he caused
I mean, it's outrageous.
It it should outrage all Americans.
You know, Stewart
Rhodes was convicted by a jury
of his peers for his actions,
which resulted in
the injuries sustained by myself
and hundreds of other police officers.
On January six.
Not to mention the fact
that America became
a national and international embarrassment
on the world stage
But I think that
this is part of a strategy,
not just a strategy on behalf of January
six defendants
like Stewart Rhodes, but also a strategy
on behalf of the former president.
You know, if the former president
was to admit that it was, in fact,
a free and fair election,
then he would also, in turn be admitting
some degree of culpability
for the violence that took place that day.
January six.
Stewart Rhodes, I think, is
he is looking for a
pardon.
It's sickening
that that the former president
would have aligned himself
with individuals like this
in the statements that he made
in this town hall and continues
to make on a daily basis
Officer Michael Fanone,
we appreciate your service on that day
as we watch video of the ugliness
that unfolded.
And we appreciate you speaking out
since then.
Thank you so much for the time
Thanks for having me.
Of course, the leader of the Oath Keepers
has just been sentenced for his actions
in the attack on the U.S.
Capitol on January 6th.
Stuart
Rhodes, the founder and leader of the far
right group, was the first of nine
defendants who were sentenced.
The judge finding that his actions
amounted to domestic terrorism
and for that,
he will be serving 18 years in prison.
We have CNN's senior crime and justice
reporter Caitlin Lance joining us now.
Caitlin, walk us through
what happened today.
Inside of court
Well, Brianna, this was a very intense
sentencing hearing
today, one where
student Stuart Rhodes expressed no remorse
for what he did on January six
and continued to espouse his belief
that the election of 2020 was illegal
and that he was a political prisoner.
But before the judge gave him
his sentence, he was sentenced
to 18 years in prison
and also some years of supervised release.
After that,
the judge was very straightforward
with Stuart Rhodes about what he did,
why seditious conspiracy
was so significant
of a crime, one that strikes
at the heart of American democracy.
He said to Stuart Rhodes,
This is the judge I made that
you are not a political prisoner,
Mr. Rhodes.
That is not why you are here.
It is not because of your beliefs.
It is not because Joe
Biden is the president right now.
The judge had many things to say to them.
Some of the other things he said
was that he believes that Rhodes is making
clear today in court when he spoke
to the judge expressing no remorse
that violence could be something
that achieved his goals
and that he continued to be a threat
to democracy.
The judge clearly took that to heart
and was saying that we cannot have this.
We cannot have citizens
believe that violence is the way
to get things done in a democracy.
And the judge also expressed some concern
of whether there would be another January
six, that any elections in the future,
they will there will be fear around them.
Because of what happened on January six.
But 18 years is quite
a significant sentence by far, the longest
that any January six riot
defendant has received
for federal crimes on that day.
And by my calculation, it puts Stuart
Rhodes in jail somewhere near
or after 2040, which is five
presidential elections from now Brianna.
Wow. Caitlin Plants, thank you.
I want to bring in Evan Perez now.
Evan, let's just be clear about
how we got to this point, what Stuart
Rhodes did leading up to January 6th
and even after January 6th.
Right.
That's part of the key evidence that
the prosecutors presented at this trial.
They said
and they showed evidence of the amount
of coordination that they say Stuart
Rhodes and some of these other members
went through before January six.
There was efforts to do some training,
military style training,
militia style
training in North Carolina, for instance.
So they stockpiled weapons in a van
in Northern Virginia
with the idea that, you know, if
and when the former president, President
Trump at the time were to declare
and invoke the Insurrection
Act, that they could be the foot soldiers,
they would be the militia
that would cross over into Washington
and help him keep power.
Even after the dust has settled on January
six, even after it was clear
that Donald Trump would be leaving.
They vowed to keep fighting on.
They vowed to keep to prevent the former
the new president,
their lawfully elected president,
Joe Biden, from being able to take office.
So those are the things that prosecutors
were successful in playing
for the jurors, showing them photographs,
showing them some of the messages
that were being exchanged that persuaded
that jury to come back with the
with the extraordinary thing,
which is to convict these people
on seditious conspiracy, essentially
trying to overthrow the US government.
And why you see this very stiff
sentence today from this judge.
18 years, the longest that has been given
to anybody in these in these cases
really the general six yet saying
that it amounts to domestic terrorism.
Really
something to hear the judge say that.
Evan Perez, Caitlin Lance, thank you.